in this lesson I'd like to go over how
to draw mechanisms and common errors I
see my students make in mechanisms and
tips to help you avoid them first of all
let's get some basics down for mechanism
writing I'm going to abbreviate
nucleophile with this end in a circle
and electrophile with this e in a circle
for this video our first rule is that
the arrow points from the nucleophile to
the electrophile the new bond forms at
the tip of the arrow so where the arrow
points you're going to be drawing your
new bond and where you start your arrow
at the origin of your arrow that bond is
going to break now it's important that
our nucleophile has extra electrons the
arrow is going to show where these
electrons are moving that's why it comes
from the nucleophile and points to the
electrophile so what are some things
that can have extra electrons so it lone
pairs on something like oxygen or
nitrogen can make new bonds and act as
nucleophiles double bonds and triple
bonds can act as nucleophiles and
sometimes our extra electrons are
represented with a negative charge and
you could show that negative charge
actually attacking and your arrow will
point from that now in this lesson we're
going to be looking at polar mechanisms
we'll start with a polar acidic
mechanism when we treat this alkene with
sulfuric acid and water we're going to
end up forming an alcohol okay let's
write our mechanism keeping these rules
in mind in water sulfuric acid is going
to lose a proton and form the hydronium
ion so we'll draw that out and show our
alkene reacting with it okay now our
arrow needs to point from the
nucleophile to the electrophile and the
nucleophile has to have extra electrons
we can see this has a positive charge
here so this is the thing that has extra
electrons to give this double bond this
is already positive so it's not going to
be a very good nucleophile but it'll be
a great electro file our first arrow is
going to show the alkene attacking one
of the protons on the hydronium ion now
it might be tempting to just show this
one arrow button mechanism writing will
show a second arrow for a bond breaking
and become
a lone pair so when we put this lone
pair on oxygen we need a second arrow
now we want to show our new bond at the
tip of the arrow so we're going to have
to put a new bond from this double bond
to the hydrogen atom now we showed the
bond coming out this way and so we're
attaching the hydrogen on this end well
that means this end of the alkyne lost
its electrons so we're going to end up
with a positive charge there now if we
follow our arrows we see our new Bond
was formed here this bond broken became
a lone pair on oxygen so we also get a
molecule of water it's a good time for
me to make another point about
mechanisms in any step of a mechanism
charge is conserved so here we have a
neutral alkene reacting with the
positive hydronium ion and so this is
neutral this is positive we need to get
a +1 out of the reaction now if you
don't have this charge balance then
you've either drawn something wrong or
you've not shown all of the products of
the step so here we have this positive
carbo cation and this neutral water so
we have an overall +1 on this side and
an overall +1 on this side so we know
we've done this correctly we need to end
up with an O H group here so water can
now attack at this carbo cation via the
oxygen atom which has extra electrons on
it so we have our nucleophile pointing
to the electrophile which is that
positive charge the carbo cation and now
we can just draw a bond connecting this
lone pair to this carbon atom and now
when we check our work we'll see I
started with a positive reacting with a
neutral and oh no I drew a neutral that
means I've missed a positive charge
somewhere the oxygen has shared its
electrons in this bond and therefore it
now has a positive charge so we can add
on our positive charge and a pair of
electrons now we're getting really close
to our product we just have an extra
hydrogen and a positive charge what can
happen next is water can come in and
deprotonate one of the
hydrogen atoms reforming a hydronium ion
and giving us our alcohol so our
nucleophile is going to be electrons
here it's the lone pair on oxygen and
we're going to point to this extra
hydrogen atom and put this lone pair
back on oxygen
this arrow pushing gives us our alcohol
and also a molecule of the hydronium ion
now before we dive into the common
errors I want to go over a basic
mechanism so this is a polar basic
mechanism this molecule is going to
cyclize it's going to form a ring and
this is going to do this by a reaction
called them intramolecular aldol I want
to show you a basic mechanism because
they're different from acidic mechanisms
though the rules remain the same now
what's going on here is we're going to
have this spot of the molecule connect
to this spot on the molecule and that
will make this ring we should notice we
have lost one of our oxygen atoms but
we've gained a double bond so let's try
to tackle this mechanism and see how it
goes we can think about sodium as a
spectator ion in our reaction so we'll
just draw na+ up here it's the O H minus
counter ion that's going to do the work
now we can see we have a negative charge
we have extra lone pairs on this oxygen
atom and that's going to be our
nucleophile the first step is going to
be deprotonation of the hydrogen atoms
that are next to the carbonyl or alpha
to it so hydroxide with its extra
electrons represented here by a negative
charge is going to point to one of these
hydrogen atoms and make a negative
charge next to the carbonyl our product
is called an enolate now this carbon
atom is a nucleophile and we can point
to this carbonyl carbon and form a bond
there because of the dipole in a
carbonyl group this is Delta negative
and this is Delta positive let's add our
arrows now here we're going to connect
with this arrow points and then we have
another arrow coming from a double bond
and we'll show that breaking at the
origin of this error
and becoming a lone pair on oxygen now
we're getting really close
we've made our ring but we still have
our oxygen and we don't have a double
bond so we want this oxygen to leave the
molecule but it'll never leave with a
pair of electrons right now cuz it would
have to leave as a two - and that's just
way too high in energy so we're gonna
put a proton on here from water first we
have this negative charge that'll be our
nucleophile and it's going to
deprotonate a proton on water be sure
not to forget that second arrow putting
the lone pair back on oxygen in the next
step we're going to analyze this
molecule again like we did up here we'll
add on the hydrogen next to the carbonyl
and use the molecule of hydroxide that
we generated from deprotonation of this
water molecule to deprotonate that
hydrogen atom
now hydroxide isn't the best leaving
group but in special situations it can
leave and where we have this negative
charge that's stabilized by the carbonyl
and it's going to form a double bond
that's in conjugation with the carbonyl
conjugation is alternating double and
single bonds here it's going to be
actually quite favorable for the
hydroxide to leave so in this case we
can show hydroxide being pushed out as
the double bond forms so this negative
charge is at the origin so it's not
going to be here anymore it's going to
move to where we've pointed giving us
our double bond and the hydroxide has
been eliminated
all right let's return to our acid
catalyzed hydration mechanism to go into
our common errors and I want to just
sort of correct one thing here I set the
bond breaks at the origin of the arrow
and that's sometimes true like in this
case where we're showing this bond
opening up a double bond but really it
might be a little bit more correct to
say that the electrons move away from
the origin so let's update our rule to
say that and it'll be a little bit more
correct here okay this first one is
pretty bad
not attacking with the nucleophile let
me show you how you might do this in
this example
say we have our alkene and we're
abbreviating the hydronium ion as just
simple h+ the way you'd make this error
is by showing h+ attacking the alkene
instead of the other way around
i see this type of error Allah
unfortunately I most often see this in
carbonyl chemistry
now the H+ can't possibly do the
attacking it doesn't have any electrons
whatsoever it's positively charged so
how do we avoid this error drawing out
all your lone pairs on your molecule is
gonna help a lot also remembering that
for the most part a neutral or negative
atom is going to do the attacking
that'll help you also
another common error I see is where the
arrows don't flow they kind of point at
each other or away from each other let
me show you an example of how I would
see this drawn using this mechanism so
we've got a couple problems here first
of all the hydrogen is again not
attacking the alkene and then this arrow
is going in this way so they're kind of
going away from each other and sometimes
they'll be going towards each other when
you make this error so your arrow should
kind of flow in the same direction now
there is one case we're looking at polar
mechanisms here and in radical
mechanisms you may see arrows there's a
way to draw that where arrows are coming
at each other so this doesn't apply to
radical reactions but in a polar
mechanism if you have arrows pointing
away or toward each other something is
probably wrong and you should revisit it
losing your charges throughout the
course of a mechanism is a big one that
I see all the time let's show an example
so here we showed our alkene attacking
H+ and we showed this product but we're
missing the charge on this carbon atom
that we had up here an easy way to avoid
this is checking the charge balance in
every step the reactants that you show
coming together whatever product you
make it should have the same overall
charge so here neutral and a plus oh no
gave us a neutral we're missing a
positive charge somewhere in this
molecule
now this next error comes from the fact
that in a solution in a reaction flask
where these reactions are occurring it
is only likely that two molecules are
going to collide
perfectly at once in the right
orientation to make a new bond so
showing more than two things coming
together is just really unlikely and so
you have to decide which step comes
first let me show you an example so if
we try to show this carbo-cation
reacting at once with two molecules of
water we might think that we're saving a
step let me show you how the arrow
pushing might look in this error so here
it looks like the lone pair is
deprotonating this and then these
electrons are coming in here but we have
to decide what happens first because
it's not likely that these three things
will come together in the correct
geometry to make this all in one step
and since this mechanism is under acidic
conditions we need to choose our steps
so that we form only positive charges
I'll get to this common error in just a
second let's jump back to our anionic
negatively charged mechanism this
intramolecular aldol to go through the
last four common errors I have for you
so often with long chains like this my
students lose points for Mis drawing
their structure here's an example
instead of making the six membered ring
they've miscounted and done a five
membered ring here an easy way to avoid
this is to number your carbons if we
number our chain then number our ring we
can easily see that we don't have the
same number of carbon atoms and we can
see that carbon three should have formed
a bond with carbon eight and here we
have three forming a bond with carbon
seven an easy error to avoid and I
number my carbons all the time now every
time you make a new bond you just want
to have one arrow to show that new bond
forming you don't need more than one now
I can't actually show this one with this
mechanism I want to show you the most
common way I see my students make this
mistake and it's when they try to
protonate a carbonyl with acid so when
showing these two things react they'd
show the arrow pushing like this now
there's actually two ways to show this
correctly the first one is just by
taking out this arrow and showing the
carbonyl get protonated at oxygen so
here's one way to show this correctly
and then we also can use an arrow that
originates
from this double bond and show it
breaking upon protonation so here we're
showing the arrow coming from the double
bond coming away from this carbon which
leaves it positive and then we just have
two bonds to oxygen in each case and
oxygen stays neutral but when you have
extra arrows to form one new bond I
think it gets a little confusing so it's
best to pick one of these styles for
your arrow pushing exceeding valence can
be a big problem in mechanism writing
and if you exceed valence your mechanism
will always be wrong we want to follow
the octet rule so we want for the most
part eight electrons around the common
atoms in organic mechanisms let me show
you how you might make this error so if
we look at this step here and we forget
to draw our second arrow we end up with
this here we know how five bonds to
carbon this puts 10 electrons around it
exceeding the octet rule and exceeding
the valence that carbon can have so it's
really important to check your
structures for the proper valence I have
a little trick to help you do this to
avoid this we'll think about going
across the periodic table starting with
carbon so here's this part of the
periodic table really good to memorize
now just count down 4 3 2 1 this number
is the number of bonds that each of
these atoms will form when it is neutral
so if you have a neutral carbon nitrogen
oxygen or fluorine you should look for
these number of bonds and of course this
is going to go right down the periodic
table so we could add in chlorine
bromine iodine here these are all going
to make one bond when they're neutral so
if you have more or less than this
number of bonds to these atoms and
they're neutral you've done something
wrong either you're missing a charge or
you've exceeded the valence another
great way to avoid this is by adding in
your lone pairs
especially on hetero atoms the last
common error I'm going to go over is
mixed-media let's look at both of our
mechanisms to think about this last
point here so we had an acidic mechanism
first and you'll notice everything along
the way was either either positively
charged or knew
trol and then in our basic mechanism
here everything is negatively charged or
neutral along the way mixed media is
essentially when you start making
positive charges in base and they can't
exist or you're making negative charges
in acid that can't possibly exist let me
show you an example using this mechanism
say we didn't know the first step of
this mechanism and we thought that maybe
this oxygen gets protonated we might
draw arrows that look like this showing
the carbonyl becoming protonated by a
molecule of water in base that'll give
us this product but we've just formed a
positive charge in sodium hydroxide if
this could even form immediately
hydroxide would deprotonate it because
this is so acidic with a negative PKA
but it really can't even form in the
first place what we can do is we can
check pk's we can set up an equilibrium
to see what will actually happen in this
case and look it up on a PKA table so
we'll draw a carbonyl and then we want
to think about it reacting with water
and then we'll look at the equilibrium
and consider this acting as an acid and
protonating this now let's add in the
pka's of the these conjugate acids water
is fifteen point seven and a protonated
carbonyl is something like minus five so
this is a really really low PKA this is
the most acidic thing we have in
solution essentially the equilibrium
lies so far this way that these species
will never exist so if we're wondering
about a step we can use the PKA table to
set up an equilibrium and see if the
protonation that we're suggesting is
actually plausible KP here if you learn
something give me a thumbs up on the way
out and for more chemistry subscribe to
my channel